Speaker 1: If you've watched me for any
amount of time at all on my channel.
I talk about race a lot. I talk
about the bigotry and the hate
that exists within the Republican Party.
I talk about the Republican Party being
the largest and most organized white
supremacy organization on the globe.
And one of the elements of that is
several members of Congress who are
avowed Christian nationalists. And along when
you hear the term Christian nationalists,
you should just automatically understand that it
is white Christian nationalists. There is no black
Christian nationalist. That's not a thing. It is a
an exclusively white byproduct of racism and fear.
If they're flavor of Christianity. And
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is one of these people.
Avowed Christian nationalist who speaks at is
invited to speak at and accepts the invitation
of Nick Fuentes to speak at White Christian
Nationalist conferences and she now on committees.
They're having a conversation in this committee
about the actions that led to the death of Tyree
Nichols in Memphis, Tennessee. Then she talks
how terrible it was. And then, inexplicably.
Expectedly but inexplicably pivots to Yeah,
that's really bad and all. But there's a lady
in the audience whose daughter was killed by
police. That woman, her daughter's name was
Ashli Babbitt and then goes on to to have sympathy
and and draw attention to a woman who tried to who
was a Q and on adherent who tried to overthrow the
United States government by force, by overturning
a free and fair election, who almost made it onto
the House floor to commit who knows what mayhem.
Watch this moment, despicable moment for Marjorie
Taylor GREENE in committee. Just the other day.
Speaker 2: Though, and it was tragic and and
extremely difficult to watch. I would also like
to point out that that city is Democrat controlled
and the five officers that have been arrested and
charged are black. And I think that this is an
is it an issue of racism or anything like that? I
think I think that the judge and that the jury and
the trial needs to work out what happened there.
But I share that with you. But I'd like to also
point something that I'd hope you share with me.
There's a woman in this room whose daughter
was murdered on January six. Ashli Babbitt
and Ashli Babbitt has there's never
been a trial. As a matter of fact,
no one has cared about the person that shot and
killed her. And no one in this Congress has really
addressed that issue. January six committee
didn't address it. And I believe that there
are many people that came in to the Capitol on
January six whose civil rights and liberties are
being violated heavily. And this committee
will, I hope, Mr. Chairman, look into those
civil rights abuses because they're happening
in a jail right here in this city. And I hope
Ms.. Norton will will care about that as well.
Speaker 1: GROSS, disgusting, reprehensible.
Yeah. Tiring. That's sad and all. Yeah, but,
you know, it's not racism because those cops
were black. You know, the real injustice is
that Ashli Babbitt was murdered. She says she
categorizes a woman who stormed the United States
Capitol with a mob. Amidst them were people with
shirts that said camp outfits on them. Parading
through the Capitol with Confederate flags.
A hangman's gallow constructed, hastily
constructed, planned and executed, built
on the lawn of the United States Capitol.
But a thousand feet from where they were
chanting Hang Mike Pence, they they came with an
objective. To overturn a free and fair election
to disenfranchize you and millions of other
Americans if you voted for Joe Biden because
they wanted their Dear leader back in office, a
violent attempt at overthrowing our government.
She wasn't murdered. And those they are securing
conviction after conviction after conviction of
these individuals who did indeed attempt
to overthrow the United States government.
For the power for the for the party of
of of of law and order. And back in the
blue and blue lives matter until it butts
up against their ideology and their base.
Tyree Nichols wasn't a domestic
terrorist. Tyree Nichols,
The accusation from the police that that ended
up killing him was that he recklessly drove,
which has been rebutted by the chief of police
herself. In Mississippi or excuse me, in Memphis.
She says there's no evidence of that. So what
we know is really there was no crime committed.
By Tyree Nichols. There's no comparison to be
drawn between Ashley Babbit, the Killing on Clown,
and Tyree Nichols. But leave it to Marjorie Taylor
GREENE. Leave it to the Chaos Caucus. Leave it to
the Republican Party to put her on a committee. To
create a spectacle and a circus and a distraction
from what really needs to be accomplished in our
country. That is where we are. So thanks a lot,
Kevin McCarthy. Bang up job you're doing is
Speaker of the House of Representatives making
cover for insurrectionists and insurrection
apologists like Marjorie Taylor GREENE.